hoy continuamos nuestra serie especial
sobre argentina compramos 300 vagones
cada uno cada uno cada uno de estos
vagones no salió un millón 90 mil
dólares
[Música]
igual de fuerte
de la búsqueda de la justicia social
argentinos queremos lo mismo aunque
pensemos distinto amigos argentinas es
uno de los pocos países del mundo que
vive con una inflación crónica una
inflación que no consigue quitarse de
encima cuando miras las estadísticas te
quedas simplemente alucinado este país
ha vivido bajo procesos inflacionarios
durante al menos las últimas cinco
décadas 50 años
de hecho desde que en 1935 se creara el
banco central de argentina la inflación
acumulada asciende a esta espectacular
cifra que veis en pantalla algo así como
la locura de 256 mil billones por ciento
y si es que no cabe ni en la pantalla lo
que viene a resultar una inflación media
anual de más del 60% desde 1935
[Música]
pero ahora bien porque los argentinos no
logran quitarse la inflación de encima
qué papel juegan todo esto la clase
política los empresarios y los
ciudadanos porque el dólar está tan
presente en la mente de los argentinos
pues atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos lo primero de todo es
saber exactamente qué entendemos por
inflación pues bien se suele decir que
hay inflación cuando los precios de los
bienes y servicios que demanda la
población de un país crecen de forma
generalizada pero por qué se produce qué
es lo que causa este fenómeno amigos
aquí es cuando entra en juego ese bien
tan especial que todos utilizamos para
realizar los intercambios el dinero
[Música]
es algo que se conoce por lo general el
dinero la moneda históricamente ha sido
metálica y su valor venía dado
precisamente por el peso y la
composición de metal que poseía cada una
cobre plata oro pero esto evidentemente
no era algo muy práctico así que con el
paso del tiempo comenzaron a emitirse
billetes convertibles en oro y plata que
claro eran más fáciles de transportar y
de fraccionar y por tanto de usar
[Música]
este sistema el de la convertibilidad
estuvo en vigor hasta los años 30 cuando
a partir de la gran depresión los países
empezaron poco a poco a abandonar el
sistema de convertibilidad finalmente en
1971 richard nixon le dio el carpetazo
final
a partir de ese momento amigos el valor
de los billetes pasó a depender
completamente de la confianza que el
mercado tuviera en el poder económico en
la solvencia del país que los emitía por
eso es habitual que sean precisamente
los billetes emitidos por los países más
ricos los que mayor valor y confianza
despiertan en el mercado
al mismo tiempo los gobiernos ya no
tenían que atesorar oro y plata para
respaldar sus monedas el final de la
convertibilidad le dio a los gobiernos
la posibilidad de utilizar tanto como
quisieran a una vieja amiga nuestra la
máquina de imprimir billetes
hasta ese momento si un gobierno quería
gastar más o subía los impuestos o pedía
dinero prestado sin embargo el fin de la
convertibilidad les dio otra posibilidad
financiar el gasto público con la
creación de nuevo dinero es decir lo que
se conoce popularmente como darle a la
máquina de imprimir billetes
aunque lo cierto es que a día de hoy
basta con pulsar una tecla
quizás creas todo el dinero electrónico
que quieras
por supuesto esto es algo que tiene
consecuencias si los bancos centrales
son prudentes y el crecimiento económico
acompaña la emisión de nuevo dinero el
efecto de la inflación no será
excesivamente dañino pero cuando los
gobiernos pasan esa barrera ahí y así
empieza un problema muy pero que muy
serio
de repente amigos se crea una demanda
artificial que por un lado empuja al
alza el precio de los bienes y por otro
lado al mismo tiempo la gente pierde
confianza en esa moneda resultado o una
inflación galopante por supuesto el
gobierno los políticos responsables de
esta situación nunca quieren reconocer
su responsabilidad motivo por el que al
final siempre se le termina echando la
culpa a los empresarios a los que se les
acusa de especuladores y avariciosos
entonces acto seguido llega a su
solución mágica que la verdad sólo sirve
para empeorar aún más las cosas los
controles de precios argentina aprueba
controles de precios para tratar de
frenar la inflación y no no penséis que
esto es una idea nueva para nada el
control de precios en la argentina una
historia repetida distintos gobiernos
desde perón alfonsín intentar
lo mismo en ningún caso tuvieron éxito y
había que terminar con un flagelo que
nos condena todo por igual y es el de la
inflación
y no hemos hecho nada
luego en el tema cambiario señor
presidente
el propio código de hammurabi
desenterrado en el año 1902 que fue
promulgado antes del 2000 antes de
cristo- fijaba precios salarios tipos de
interés y tarifas esto hace que los
controles de precios tengan al menos
4000 años de edad
claro que como esto tampoco funciona y
los precios de hecho suben aún más
entonces los políticos suelen empezar a
subir los salarios por decretos y a
gastar más en planes de todo tipo todo
financiado con más emisión de dinero sin
respaldo es una especie de círculo
vicioso que no hace sino crear más y más
inflación lo que supone destruir el
valor de los ahorros del capital de un
país aniquilar la seguridad jurídica e
impedir el cálculo empresarial
imprescindible para tomar decisiones y
depreciar la moneda nacional amigos en
pocos países del mundo conocen tan bien
este proceso como la argentina
la tierra de la inflación
[Música]
os lo hemos contado ya en varios vídeos
aquí en visual político la situación
económica de la argentina es terrorífica
hoy estamos acá no porque hicimos en
contra de edad
nosotros nosotros somos santidad y
estamos a favor de nuestro futuro porque
creemos que merecemos vivir vengo
poco trabajo salarios bajos impuestos
altísimos unas cuentas públicas de esas
prosas y sobre todo mucha muchísima
inflación amigos el proceso
inflacionario de la argentina lleva
creciendo sin parar desde los años 50
argentina en el podio la inflación
interanual del 51,3 por ciento es la
tercera más alta del mundo sólo por
detrás de venezuela y zimbabwe
ahora bien se cumple el proceso que
hemos descrito de quién diantres es la
responsabilidad de toda esta espiral
inflacionaria pues amigos atentos a este
cuadro elaborado por el economista
nicholas cachanosky donde podemos ver el
auténtico descontrol en el que viven las
cuentas públicas argentinas da igual
quien gobernara ya fuera militar civil
peronista o radical todos los gobiernos
se dedicaron a gastar de forma
descontrolada recurriendo para ello
tanto a la emisión de deuda primero
interna y luego también externa como a
la emisión monetaria eso es precisamente
lo que ha causado el desastre económico
que vive hoy el país
[Música]
y
si lo habéis escuchado bien ni
importaciones ni capitales wifi ni la
avaricia de los empresarios esto es como
una mentira que la repiten mil veces y
al final se acaba convirtiendo en verdad
la verdad es que los enormes déficits
públicos se han financiado y se siguen
financiando con una enorme deuda externa
y también con altísimas tasas de
inflación es decir con la máquina de
imprimir billetes ojo a este cuadro
donde podéis ver las tasas de inflación
anual media que tuvo cada presidente de
la argentina desde 1943
[Música]
algunos presidentes estuvieron poco
tiempo en el poder incluso menos de un
año otros estuvieron en el sillón
presidencial bastante más tiempo
presidentes tan conocidos como perón
videla o alfonsín cristina fernández de
kirchner o mauricio macri tuvieron
muchas diferencias entre sí pero
prácticamente todos los presidentes
tuvieron algo en común las altísimas
tasas de inflación este proceso amigos
ha sido tan constante que ha hecho que
los argentinos se acostumbren a vivir
con inflaciones y enormes claro que eso
no suaviza en absoluto sus desastrosos
efectos económicos sino que incluso
puede empeorar los
es lógico al final cuando te acostumbras
a que la moneda pierda valor tan rápido
todos los miembros del mercado actúan en
consecuencia los empresarios tratan de
compensar el riesgo por ejemplo subiendo
aún más los precios los sindicatos
exigen subidas de salario por si las
moscas y el gobierno para tratar de
compensar todos los problemas económicos
y sociales que se han creado no para de
aprobar regulaciones de todo tipo de
emitir deuda en moneda extranjera porque
claro llega un momento en el que los
mercados financieros locales ya no
sirven de nada y por supuesto de darle
una y otra vez a la maquinita de
imprimir billetes y esto es un suma y
sigue una especie de carrera organizada
e impulsada por los políticos en la que
todos los participantes pierden
especialmente los más pobres los que
dependen de su salario para sobrevivir
de socios prebendarios sindicalistas
mafiosos y políticos ignorantes y
corruptos
y es que no podemos engañarnos un efecto
claro de las elevadas inflación es es
que destruyen la competitividad de un
país como pues primero consumiendo el
ahorro el capital local y luego además
cuando los gobiernos para hacer frente a
los incrementos descontrolados de
precios introducen restricciones de todo
tipo terminan creando industrias
economías incapaces de competir en el
mundo
esto amigos es lo que ocurre
precisamente en la argentina y por eso
argentina no sale de una crisis si no es
para meterse en otra y ojo es que
hablamos de más de 50 años y oye que no
hay manera que los políticos argentinos
no aprenden
déficit fiscal recurrente en 2018 el
estado cubrió sólo el 85 por ciento de
sus gastos con ingresos genuinos
argentinas deudas acerca el 97,7 por
ciento del pib del país y es la más alta
de la región
ahora veamos la pregunta es tienen los
argentinos algún mecanismo de defensa
existe algún instrumento que pueda
ayudarles a protegerse del
empecinamiento de los políticos pues si
en cierto modo hay uno atentos
el mundo del dólar
[Aplausos]
no hace falta ser premio nobel de
economía para saber que tener ahorros en
pesos argentinos es una mala malísima
idea es algo que todos los que nos veis
desde argentina sabéis perfectamente
y es que si tu moneda pierde valor cada
día de una forma tan importante entonces
no te queda otra que buscarte otra
moneda para conservar mejor el valor de
tus ahorros y esa moneda en el caso de
argentina y de prácticamente todos los
países del mundo con este mismo problema
es el dólar estadounidense la economía
argentina está dolarizada de facto falta
hacerlo de iure
en argentina es habitual que todo hijo
de vecino sepa igual de bien cuál es el
día en el que vive como el tipo de
cambio del dólar con el peso argentino
ese día y es que para los argentinos el
dólar es importante por varios motivos
primero porque el precio de los
productos está muy ligado a la
cotización del dólar veréis me explico
como argentina tiene que importar muchos
bienes y con una moneda el peso que
pierde valor tan rápido prácticamente
todo se negocia en dólares que por otra
parte es la moneda de reserva
internacional exactamente lo mismo
ocurre con las exportaciones argentinas
el dólar es más estable y al final se
termina convirtiendo en la unidad de
referencia los precios en pesos vienen a
ser algo así como un termómetro loco que
continuamente cambia la temperatura
en segundo lugar y la cuestión más
importante es porque el dólar es una
moneda que le permite a los argentinos
mantener el valor de sus ahorros si es
verdad el dólar también sufre el
problema de la inflación pero en
proporciones nada comparables a la del
peso argentino por ejemplo si en el año
2001 hubiéramos guardado en un cajón 20
mil pesos el equivalente entonces a un
coche medio en 2019 con ese mismo dinero
apenas podríamos comprarnos un
smartphone y no al iphone no llegaríamos
la pérdida de valor del peso argentino
es simple y llanamente dramática
[Música]
esto es lo que explica amigos que en los
países con una alta inflación en el
dólar circule casi como si se tratara de
una moneda nacional ocurre en argentina
pero es que incluso en corea del norte
se utiliza el dólar desde 1950 la
argentina apenas ha experimentado 10
años entre 1993 y 2002 en los que la
inflación se situó en niveles moderados
por debajo del 4% diez años en casi
siete décadas de esta forma la argentina
se ha convertido en uno de los pocos
países del mundo que no consigue
controlar su inflación y es que no nos
engañemos la solución es clara reducir
el gasto público y equilibrar los
presupuestos y dejar de depender del
banco central los políticos lo saben la
pregunta es por qué diantres no lo
aplican y esto me lleva a otra pregunta
serán los políticos argentinos capaces
de acabar con esta interminable espiral
inflacionaria pero eso os lo dejo a
todos vosotros dejadme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si este
el resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like i suscribiros a
visual político este año además
hablaremos mucho de argentina y puede
que hasta con alguna sorpresa un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]
una vez